from a grizzly bloodbath to flying
french body parts prey offers up some of
the predator franchise's most gruesome
kills spoilers ahead
while the famous alien hunter is known
by the name predator it's merely a
reference to what it does for sport it
hunts the species however only hunt
other predators animals that can fight
back otherwise there's no sport in the
affair being new to planet earth in this
film the predator begins hunting
wildlife it first kills a rattlesnake it
even eventually kills a massive grizzly
bear but at one point however it targets
a wolf just like with its human prey the
predator stalks the wolf using thermal
vision however the wolf is only out to
get lunch eyeing a tasty looking rabbit
after the wolf gives chase it nabs the
furry snack right as the predator
strikes the two predators then spar with
the alien hunter getting the better of
the canine later in the film the alien
hunter is seen polishing the wolf's
skull it's a clear callback to the
predator's tendency to claim trophies
one of the most harrowing moments in the
film comes when naru encounters a
grizzly bear the animal in all of its
ferocity sets its sights on naru and
aims to kill her naru flees and spots a
beaver dam in the middle of the river
she dives underneath the water's surface
and pulls herself up inside the
fortified beaver home meanwhile the
predator hones in on the massive bear
intent on collecting another trophy the
predator is strong enough to pull its
kill from out of the dam and hoist the
massive mammal over its head naru stares
in terror as the cloaked predator lets
the animal's blood pour over its body
it's a powerful iconic moment for the
franchise
perhaps one of nauru's biggest
detractors wasape leads the hunting
party with all the bravado he can muster
he has zero faith that naaru can be an
effective hunter with his snide comments
who invited you
we won't be gone long enough to need a
cook
it was always clear from the get-go that
wasap's ego was going to get him into
trouble and lead to his demise when the
comanche hunting party hears strange
sounds in the woods they become wary a
creature is making guttural clicking
noises high in the trees but they're
unsure what sort of animal it could be
after wasabe kills a possum thinking it
was causing the rustling in the woods he
goes to retrieve it that's when three
red dots appear on his chest he is
swiftly killed with three darts shortly
after
like most of us have come to expect
there's a moment when the comanche
hunters face a mass slaughter at the
hands of the predator the moment comes
after the hunters embark on a trip to
track down naaru she's left camp to hunt
and investigate this strange new visitor
on her own if they don't see
[Music]
we'll show them
while on the prowl for the lion earlier
nauru insists to tabe that they aren't
alone in the forest her senses are keen
as she notes the oddly skinned snake
from earlier after finding an injured
fellow hunter who was attacked by the
mountain lion naru rightfully wonders
why the mountain lion didn't finish him
off she postulates to her brother that
something scared it away furthermore the
native hunters suggest the tracks left
behind her from a bear though naru
correctly points out that the tracks
indicate an animal walking on its hind
legs unknown to the warriors the
predator watches and waits for the right
moment to strike after killing wasabe
the rest of the hunters jump into attack
fighting this hulking beast one on one
is a bad call however no matter how
skilled these warriors are their
abilities are no match for the physical
prowess of the predator it begins
systematically butchering them one by
one it's a bloody sequence that sets a
precedent for the massacre of the fur
trappers still to come
it's a is a member of tabe's band of
comanche hunters who initially endeavors
to slay a mountain lion in the battle
sequence where the predator rears its
ugly head and slaughters nearly the
entire hunting party i'd say is nowhere
to be seen after nauru flees from the
alien hunter she finds herself in a
field of tall grass it's a grabs her and
pulls her below the grass and motions to
her to be silent it's say indicates that
he can see the beast steadying his bow a
trio of targeting lasers appears on his
forehead nauru knowing exactly what that
means is quick on the draw and causes
the predator to miss his shot nauru only
buys poor it's a precious seconds
however as the predator gives chase
still invisible following them through
the tall grass the predator closes in
the creature runs itse down in the field
and guts him in a grisly display
after the predator has eviscerated most
of the comanche hunting party the fur
trappers remain alongside naru and tabe
of course the fur trappers attempt to
use naru and tabe as bait for the alien
hunter by tying them to a tree however
naru knows from experience that the
predator won't target her and her
brother while they're incapacitated
instead it's going to hunt all the fur
trappers lying in wait of course what
ensues is a massive slaughter of the fur
trappers the predator actively uses all
of its tools and moves dismembering the
hunter's left and right at one point it
choke holds a man to a tree and then
activates its gauntlet shield that opens
up and decapitates the man it even
wields the weapons brought by the fur
traders including an axe and lobs off
another man's arm before finishing the
job one unfortunate soul aims his pistol
directly at the predator point blank the
predator stands still as if beckoning
the man to fire when he finally pulls
the trigger the bullet ricochets off the
predator's helmet and brings a swift end
to the trapper the predator ends his
massacre by leaving behind a wrist
gauntlet containing three explosive
drones that eliminate the rest of their
party
rafael adollini is the name inscribed on
the flintlock pistol the predators gave
to detective mike harrigan at the end of
predator 2. it was a cool nod to the
idea that the crew of alien hunters had
been visiting earth for a few centuries
that very flintlock pistol becomes a key
tie-in to the prequel film prey credited
only as raphael he is one of the
trappers who initially finds and
imprisons naru after she is snagged by
their bear trap while imprisoned at
their camp raphael is the only one who
speaks her language and can translate
for the other fur trappers the only
thing they want to know is any details
she can share on the beast that is
hunting them later in the film all of
the fur trappers are slaughtered by the
predator one lone trapper makes it back
alive raphael though his leg is severed
below the knee he asks for naru's help
in exchange for his flintlock pistol
unfortunately when the predator arrives
it finds the incapacitated ardulini is
still alive and finishes what it started
adelini may have been a random fur
trapper but his flintlock pistol is a
cool relic that connects the great
predator universe
perhaps one of the most emotionally
upsetting deaths at the hands of the
predator is tabe naru's brother while he
displays a measure of doubt about his
sister's hunting skills it's more likely
that he's being protective of her
however he does ultimately relent and
allows her to join the hunt during their
trek naru shares her anxieties over
another hunter in the woods given the
strangely skinned snake and the odd
attack patterns she is tracking from
animals in the wilderness tabe dismisses
naru's instincts however a move he won't
soon forget of the entire comanche
hunting party tabe manages to outlast
them all standing strong right beside
his sister when naru is attacked by the
predator in the fur trapper's camp tabe
jumps into the fray with nauru making
one final request of her
this is it
no
bring it home
it's a loving message for her to finish
the job knowing he won't survive combat
with the beast the predator does get the
better of him and impales tope through
the back with its wrist mounted claws
when the predator targets naru tabe who
is seemingly dead gets one final blow
and injures the alien hunter's leg but
meets his end as a result this fuels her
motivation to end the predator once and
for all
no matter how ferocious the predator may
be the odds are stacked against it when
it comes to surviving the film but it's
not brute's strength that gives humans
an advantage a fight with a predator
comes down to a game of wits every human
victor always bests the alien by
outsmarting it at its own game
naru is a master at this early in the
film she is temporarily trapped in a bog
but manages to pull herself to safety
using her axe and rope as the final
confrontation approaches naru uses her
flintlock pistol to knock the predator's
mask off robbing it of its targeting
system she takes the mask and positions
it to aim at the bog she intends to pull
the predator into the mire where the
creature will be forced to shoot at her
from a distance however its weaponry is
guided by the mask's targeting system
when active once the predator does fall
for her trap and makes the fatal mistake
of pulling the trigger the bolt bends
away from nauru and ricochets off
multiple trees before plunging right
through the predator's skull in effect
she tricks the beast into killing itself
this time the human victor takes a
trophy from the predator something that
hasn't happened in previous films as she
walks back into her camp it's clear that
naru has become as vicious as the alien
beast that's doctor
[Music]